- It's been a couple years.
So I heard that you have a grandson now.
- I have my first grandchild.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] How exciting.
It's way more fun with grandkids, right?
- [Guest] Oh my God. I had no idea
I had this much untapped
love inside of me.
- [Kelly] Look at that face?
- And the cool thing was
my daughter got on Jerry Springer
and we were able to find
out who the father is
without--
(audience laughing)
Spending one dime of our own money.
(Kelly laughs)
- cleared it right up.
Wait, so is he gonna call
you something Southern
like Papa or anything?
- All right. So years ago when I was doing
"Are You Smarter Than a 5th Grader?"
I wrote three children's books.
And a friend of mine,
his little girl,
couldn't say my name.
And so she would always go,
"Dad, let's read the Jex Fox Worley book."
(some laugh)
And, so when my kids heard that
they never called me dad again.
They just called me Jex. J-E-X.
And I thought, well--
- [Kelly] Which is cute.
Little kids can say it,
that'll be my granddad name.
I'll just be Jex.
Well, and my wife was Gaga
so my son-in-law's mom forgot our names
like a couple months in, and she said,
"So how is Gaga and Chex Mix doing?"
(audience laughing)
And so, now my kids heard that
and that's all they call...
They call me Chex Mix.
(audience laughing)
So I'm gonna be the only
granddad in the world--
It's like, who would go,
"Should I be Pringles?"
- [Kelly] "Muddy buddies?"
(Kelly laughs)
- "You know, I'll be Chex Mix"
- I like Chex Mix.
So they call you Chex Mix?
Yeah. When I walk in
and then they have my
grandson, they're like,
"Chex Mix!"
(all laugh)
(Kelly animates)
Yeah.
- I love that.